So we have seen some relatively
general fault tolerance techniques.
Now let's look at the fault tolerance
techniques for memory and storage.
We could use dual modular redundancy or
triple modular redundancy for memory and
storage, but they are considered
to be overkill for these devices.
We can get better techniques that
protect us from similar problems.
So dual modular redundancy and triple
modular redundancy are typically used
for the hardware that does the
computation, which cannot be protected
by some of the less expensive
techniques that memory and
storage can benefit from and
these techniques for memory and
storage are called error detection or
error correction codes.
So the idea is that we can store bits
with some x-ray information that allows
us to detect and, or correct one or more
bits of error, depending on the code.
So we don't have to store everything
twice or everything three times in
order to receive detection or
correction of a single error.
The simplest technique that is often
used for memory storage is parity.
With parity, we add one extra bit to
the data bits and that extra bit,
you can compute simply as
an XOR of all the data bits.
When we do have parity,
if a fault flips any one of the bits,
including the parity bit.
The parity bit will no
longer match the data.
By flipping one of the bits,
we are changing the result of this XOR
to be the opposite of
what it previously was.
So when we read the data
in the parity and
we see that now the parity
does not match data, we assume
that there has been a bit flip and
that's how we detect a single bit error.
The next level of error detection and
correction codes is the so-called ECC,
which stands for error correction code.
And a typical example of this would be
a type of code called SECDED codes or
single error correction and
double error detection code.
So this code can detect any one
bit flip and actually fix it or
if there are 2 bit flips,
we will found out that that happened,
but we can no longer
fix it using this code.
An example of where this type
of a code is used is in data
modules that have ECC.
This is how they are protected.
So pretty much if there is a single
bit flip in such a module,
you don't even notice.
Everything functions well.
If there are two errors in the data that
is protected by the same code, then we
will get notified that there's been an
error, but we cannot continue operating
normally, because actually we cannot
correct the error in this state anymore.
Hard drives use even fancier codes,
such as the Reed-Solomon codes,
that I'm not going to go into here.
And these codes can detect and
correct multiple bit errors and
they're especially powerful when
we have a streak of flipped bits,
which happens, for example,
when the head oscillates a little bit.
And while the disk is spinning it for
a while,
just is too high above the platter and
misses some of the bits.
And then for hard drives in addition
to these error detection and correction
codes, there is a family of techniques
called RAID that we will look at next.